let's say the 2011 nominal GDP is
fifteen thousand two hundred ninety four
point three billion dollars and I didn't
just make this number up this is
actually the advanced estimate of what
2011's GDP was in the fourth quarter and
now this isn't just the fourth quarter
number they took the fourth quarter
number and then they annualized this to
get to this fifteen thousand billion
which is essentially fifteen point two
nine four three trillion dollars of GDP
now let's say the GDP deflator relative
to 2010 you always have to know what
you're taking your deflator relative to
is a hundred and two point five and this
is once again this is the 2011 this is
the 2011 GDP deflator and one way to
interpret this is if the base year is
2010 that means that prices in 2010
could be viewed as being at a hundred
and that now that we are in 2011 we are
at a hundred and 2.5 or another way to
think about it is that the general level
of prices and we've already talked about
this this is not an easy thing to
measure
but they've attempted to do that the
general level of prices has gone up by
two and a half percent went from one
hundred to one hundred and two point
five now that out of the way we know the
nominal GDP is the GDP measured in 2011
dollars often called the current dollar
GDP we know what the deflator is can we
figure out the real GDP in 2011 and it
will be the real GDP in 2010 dollars
when we have the 2002 flater relative to
2010 so to do that we just have to
remember that the ratio between our
nominal GDP nominal GDP and our real GDP
is going to be the ratio it's going to
be the ratio you could view it as our
current dollars versus 2010 dollars or
another way of viewing it is it's the
ratio between our deflator our deflator
which is 100 and 2.5 and 100 which is
essentially you could view that as kind
of the deflator in 2010 or we're just
setting that level of prices to be a
hundred our prices now are the hundred
and two point five so thinking of it
that way our
our nominal current dollar GDP is
fifteen thousand two hundred ninety four
point three billion dollars or you could
view that it's fifteen point two nine
four three trillion either way our real
GDP is what we want to figure out we do
not know what this is and we know our
deflator we know that things have gotten
two-and-a-half percent more expensive or
that our deflator is a hundred and two
point five one hundred and two point
five and then we can just solve for we
can just solve for the real GDP and
102.5 over one hundred you might be able
to do this one in your head this whole
expression right over here just becomes
one point zero two five and so you have
this fifteen trillion fifteen point
something trillion divided by the real
is equal to 1.0 to five or you can
divide both sides by 1.0 to five and
multiply both sides by the real GDP so
let's do that we scroll over to the left
a little bit so I'm going to multiply
both sides by the real GDP so I'm going
to multiply both sides by the real GDP
I'm going to divide both sides by 1.0 to
five 1.0 to five 1.0 to five now of
course this cancels with that that's why
I multiplied both sides by the real and
then this cancels with that and we get
our real GDP I'll just swap well I'll
leave it over here are real let me do it
in that same blue color our real GDP is
equal to our current dollar GDP fifteen
thousand two hundred ninety four point
three billion dollars divided by
essentially the ratio between our
deflator and one hundred divided by 1.05
if I were in charge of naming
macroeconomic concepts I would have
actually made this the deflator I would
have set this at one and I would have
called this 1.0 to five because then you
wouldn't had all this silliness of
multiplying and dividing by 100 you just
say let's take our current dollar GDB
divide it by the deflator i guess you
could say we're going to deflate it to
get the real GDP you just make a lot
more sense to me but either way that's
essentially what it simplified to this
is our current dollar GDP our nominal
GDP dividing it by what I would have
preferred to call the deflator but you
could do this as a deflator divided by
100 and that gives us our real GDP we're
just a flood we're deflating the card
dollar 1 and I'm going to need a
calculator to figure this one out so
let's get the calculator out so we're
just do everything in billion fifteen
thousand two hundred ninety four point
three this is in billions tah or / so
our answer is going to be in billions
one point zero two five gives us 14
thousand nine hundred twenty-one point
three so let me take that off the screen
so I can remember what that says I have
a bad memory all right so this is our
real GDP our real GDP is equal to
fourteen thousand two hundred oh no 921
921 0.3 so I'm rounding billion dollars
that is equal to our real GDP 1414
thousand billion or fourteen point nine
thousand billion is the same thing you
could also write this this is same thing
as fourteen point nine two one three
trillion trillion trillion dollars